the Joe Rogan experience have you met
Verner Hertzog
I've not are you in yes yes he is one of
my all-time favorite movies ooh it's one
of the best unintentional comedies ever
and I don't think it's a particularly
unintentional there's a [ __ ] moment
in that film where the sheriff when the
sheriff's talking about like the body
and they carrying the body off in bags
yeah it's like you know what did you
think well first time I heard about I
thought he was [ __ ] and then they
could just has a smash cut to the
sheriff's face and I'm [ __ ] howling
yeah I'm howling laughing and I'm like
this guy did this on purpose like
there's so many cuts in this movie that
are so humorous yeah I got to thank that
and Werner Herzog's have you ever heard
him on Eric Weinstein is podcast no
brilliant guy oh yeah he's really
interesting intense guy and very dark
sense of humor right yeah yeah yeah
well that's why I thought I was like
this [ __ ] did this on purpose
yeah I made this a comedy so do you
think that what was the name of the
character Timothy Treadwell yes yeah yes
when I watched that movie my feeling was
this guy is closeted gay dude 100% yeah
you felt that he brings up if I was gay
it would be easy but I'm not gay right
so he says because you say why can't I
find a girl you know he's like walking
through the woods with this like lispy
gay way of talking yeah and he's talking
to the good for people don't know what
this documentary is about it's about a
guy named Timothy Treadwell and Timothy
Treadwell was well I guess you could say
he was a bear expert but not really
because the real bear experts real like
this guy doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
doing get out of there like what he's
doing as Rudy doesn't need to protect
these bears he's pretending that he's
protecting these bears he's living with
them I think there was a certain element
of it that was suicide by bear yeah I
really do
and he was walking through the woods
holding this camcorder getting film
going if I was gay it'd be so easy right
talking that camcorder as his only
friend yes he's out there alone for
months yeah every summer but no one
who's not gay says well if I was gay it
would be really easy and I said that a
lot just less you're being funny
with a friend yeah like well if I was
gay I'll just hook up with some dudes
but he's saying it like why can't I find
a girl if I was gay be so easy no
wouldn't you're still living the woods
with monsters I'm gonna get a bunch of
gay guys okay guys they want to be in
Boystown okay they should remake the
movie in a bear bar on Broadway that
would be hilarious yeah instead of doing
it with the forest actual grizzly bears
in the West Village yeah yeah if I was
gay bears everywhere I went to a bear
bar with Andrew Sullivan and Dan Savage
there's there's actually a bear bar oh
there are lots of bear bars they call
bear bars yeah yes and for people don't
know what we're talking about bears are
big hairy gay guys gay guys think Tom
Segura and Bert Kreischer two bears one
cave oh do it
that's hilarious but neither one of them
is gay but yeah that's not the point but
if they were gay they'd be big yeah yeah
yeah I don't know
bears Dan Savage is a trip I've had him
on the potty yeah
yeah I know I saw that it was
interesting he's an interesting guy he's
he's super smart and funny as [ __ ] yeah
and he's armed with nothing but a sense
of humor and a great intellect and a big
heart he's an honesty yeah yeah he's
changed the world he saves who knows how
many lives you know he's a he's
beautiful I really like to animals yeah
when someone can just be themselves
again you know that's who he is and
Timothy Treadwell if he had listened to
Dan Savage everything would be different
well that leap man that coming out leap
[ __ ] it's gotta be so hard for people I
know several guys that are closeted and
it's torturous yeah torturous to see and
one of them you know I've talked to him
I was like just come out man I'm gonna
give us a [ __ ] we don't care you don't
care you it'll be a giant relief you
know just they worry about especially
you know actors you know they worry
about the careers yeah
yeah I mean what you know when your
career is more important than the the
integrity of yourself I don't think it
hurts you I don't believe it
I don't believe it the only thing that
would hurt with actors is leading man
yeah Rock Hudson kind of guy yeah that's
one thing that's [ __ ] real like if
you're out like I don't know if Tom
Cruise is gay but that's always been
this stupid rumor right let's let's
assume it's true yeah if he did come out
in the closet man nobody wants to go see
a movie where he's a leading man he's
got a wife and kids
you'd be like that guy's sucking dick
look you never buy into it there's no
like a gay woman like Jodie Foster
right could easily play a straight woman
right in a movie and no one care fine
but when a gate that's that that is the
[ __ ] glass ceiling in Hollywood it's
one of them right when a gay man comes
out of the closet those roles with John
Travolta or whatever it is whoever
whoever would be I don't he's gay either
but if he was that's that [ __ ] that's
that's where the buck stops you cannot
be the leading man who's the married guy
with kids yeah or the the hot man who's
you know in a sexual relationship with a
woman if we know that you're having sex
with men but then it's funny right we
can watch straight actors pretend to be
gay like mountain shots no problem sure
no problem
yeah very strange yeah it's it's that's
one of the last open prejudices that we
all accept because no one's been able to
bridge that gap except what's that
dude's name that fucking's got three
names little skinny guy used to be on a
sitcom How I Met Your Mother
mmm Neil Patrick Harris yeah do he
housing yeah that guy he's openly gay
and did he play a womanizer on a sitcom
I think on How I Met Your Mother
yeah yeah I've never watched it but the
thing about sitcoms is they're like
plays like those kind of sitcoms in
front of an audience they're horseshit
mmm you know it's like it's not it's not
like a movie there's were [ __ ] you know
you know it's worth [ __ ] everyone knows
it's horseshit anything with a laugh
track and very suspicious or studio
audience like happy days like I love
Henry Winkler
but the Fonz yeah that's horseshit no
wait he's Henry Winkler gay no I don't
think so maybe I always assumed he was
as he was so overcompensating with the
Fonz I think
was a character meet him in real life he
is the nicest guy I've ever met
yeah he's in Barry now right yeah he
plays an acting coach and Barry I
haven't seen a guy here has never seen
Barry he's a fly fisherman he wrote a
book on fly fishing and I think the
books called I never met an idiot on the
river hmm because like there's something
about fly-fishing
[Applause]